and the man at the center of the rollout
of the vaccine the minister for covert
vaccine deployment and deemed sowing
uh joins us once again on the program
minister great to see you as always
um and of course plenty to discuss
around the vaccine roller but
but i wonder if we might start with that
which has been pretty widely trailed
that we are about to see some additional
controls at our borders
are we about to see the introduction of
quarantine hotels
well we review our border policy like
any other responsible country
where germany canada have done a similar
thing in january
we've done that with the pre-departure
testing
that is now required to enter the uk and
of course with passenger locator forms
uh there will be an announcement on this
issue
uh later on uh today so um
i can only say to you that uh it's right
thing to do because i'm the vaccine
minister
uh that as we vaccinate more of the
adult population
if there are new variants like the south
african variant or the brazilian
variant uh we need to be very careful we
acted on those very quickly
and of course uh dealt with travel from
those countries and from portugal and
elsewhere
rapidly so it's important that we
continue to review our border policy an
announcement will be made when decisions
taken and of course the industry itself
as i've just seen in your report
will be engaged with heavily including
matt hancock
engaging with the industry to explain uh
the decision-making at
health as well as of course uh the
business department with the business
secretary
um some might challenge the contention
that we are
dealt with this particular situation
quickly we knew about the kent variant
you know
middle of december we are now the tail
end of january
we look at countries around the world
that have managed to contain coveted
infections australia new zealand i mean
those two countries that i just
mentioned
introduced quarantine hotels you know
not this year not the tail end of
last year but in march of 2020 aren't we
once again
just a bit too late to this well the
moment the prime minister was informed
about the new variant if you recall
any which i'm sure you do because you've
been tracking this very carefully on sky
was on the 18th of december on the 19th
of december we
entered into the fourth the fourth
strictest category and then very quickly
moved on to the national
lockdown uh of course countries have to
review their borders the
germany and canada i just mentioned to
you both did that
in january we also tightened up
with the pre-departure testing and of
course passenger locator forms
and it's right that we now have a
vaccination program
which uh yes they reach six and a half
million people
with the first dose as we vaccinate more
people
it becomes more and more important that
we protect against any new variants
coming in as uh the
cmo the chief medical officer the deputy
chief medical firm
explained uh once you have that
protection
and you don't have new variant in the
country you should protect against them
it's it's when they are spreading
that it becomes negligible in terms of
difference in terms of what you do at
the border once they're already
on your shores and spreading heavily um
but but your advice
to people kind of currently thinking
about what they might be doing this
summer would presumably be
don't be booking any holidays right now
absolutely at the moment look we've
reached base camp if i can describe it
as that with the vaccine deployment
program
six and a half million over 65 million
people now
with the first dose a long way to go
we've had a tremendous performance
the nhs family the the our armed forces
of course the private sector and the
brilliant volunteers
have come together to deliver this
deployment i think
it's far too early uh in you know this
still 37 000 people in hospital with
covid at the moment
it's far too early for us to begin to
speculate about the summer
um let's talk vaccine supply for a
second in particular that route that
appears to be brewing with the european
union and astrazeneca i mean
has the european union threatened to
block the movement of vaccines
produced on the continent to the united
kingdom
i spoke to associated chief executive
pascal sorio last night
and i'm confident that associate and
pfizer
and i have to commend pfizer as well and
albert burler
for both these these are great global
companies that have promised the whole
world
uh that they will reduce billions of
doses
of vaccine because no one is stating we
are all safe
uh i'm confident that they will both
deliver for us the quantities that we
need to meet
our mid-february target and of course
beyond that
and i think but has the european union
threatened to block i mean obviously the
astrazeneca production is in the main in
the united kingdom it's the fisa
supply and we've seen some pretty
positive data around fizer of course
which i'm sure you've seen as well so
has there been an explicit threat that
the fires are vaccine
might be held up at the european union
border rather than coming here
no i'm confident that the fisa vaccine
will be delivered
pfizer have uh made sure they've always
delivered for us they will continue to
do so they have
made very important announcements on uh
the equitable supply of the whole world
including the european union i'm sure
they will deliver for the european union
and for the united kingdom and for the
rest of the world this is a great
company
great corporate citizen as is astrovedic
as is moderna
and of course other vaccines that are
coming online we have
got 367 million vaccines
that we have ordered from seven
different suppliers
so i'm confident we will meet our target
and continue to vaccinate
the whole of the adult population by the
order
is all this perhaps a bit of sarah
grapes in the european union perhaps
around the basis that we simply signed a
better deal
well i think look the european union has
to
uh make decisions uh the way it has to
make decisions we will always support
them they are our neighbors our friends
our allies our
trading partners uh i think it will be
very unwise for me to engage
in uh their negotiations or their
deliberations on their vaccine policy i
think it's much
wiser for me just to focus on delivery
for the united kingdom and of course
then for the whole world we are
the biggest contributors to the global
effort 1.3 billion pounds going into
uh kovacs which uh 450 million kovacs
and the balance
into sepia and gavin uh to deliver
vaccines the poorest countries in the
world because look
you said it earlier we're talking about
border policy no one is safe
until the whole world is safe from this
which is why we need to work together
rather than as uh the head of w.h.o has
said
rather than vaccine nationalism we
should really begin to work together now
to deliver for the whole world
can we just have a very quick question
on schools and i suspect the
ministers are becoming slightly
frustrated with the number of times that
they are being asked
there's a story in the times today which
which an open letter
10 of the uk's talks experts in child
health saying that anxiety self-harm
suicidal thoughts are at frightening
levels now i'm not asking you to put a
date
on when our children will be back in
schools when will we know
whether or not they're going to be going
in after whether or not they'll be going
in after the february half time
so as the prime minister says as we look
at data all the time there's been some
encouraging data
from public health england on primary
schools and uh
the infection rates amongst primary
school children much lower
five times higher in secondary schools
we will review all
later but the price specific
specifically when will we know if our
children will be going back into schools
on mass
after after the february half time
really straightforward
well once we see infection rates drop as
as public health said
to levels that are safe and acceptable
then we will give notice first of all to
schools
and then on your program as well we want
to give notice as much notes to teachers
and schools so so the default position
is the schools are not
reopening right now that there is
there is no suggestion from from your
position it would appear
that the schools are are going to be
opening after the february halftime
well first of all it's worth just making
sure your
viewers understand teachers schools are
open for the children of course
online and the most vulnerable children
so they're doing an amazing job and i
want to thank them
for that of course to reopen completely
which is what we want to do the privacy
priority
is to get schools open as quickly as
possible we've got to look at both
the infection rates nationally 37 000
people are
in hospital today suffering with covert
and of course look at how we do that
in primary which looks like public
health england see that
infection rates are much lower than in
secondary schools and then of course in
secondary schools
it will happen it will happen as a
priority i can't give you a timeline
because
it's wrong for me to speculate but all i
can say to you it is an
absolute priority ahead of everything
else to get schooled back open
and i commend robert hauser chairman of
the educational committee for making
sure
that he uh is championing the cause
of uh schools and education because it
is the
thing you know i have an eight-year-old
and i can tell you it's hard to do
online schooling
we're doing it i completely i completely
understand we're we're we have a such a
finite amount of time here minister i i
do want to push on to another topic and
this may well be one that you you may
well need to go off and and come back to
us on
my colleague joe pike has been looking
at a a quite alarming
uh situation in a number of hospitals we
do not yet know if this is the case
across
hospitals in england but it appears that
many of them have a policy
not to vaccinate in patients people who
have gone into hospital with other
conditions
i'll give you a couple of examples and
we had uh jan
uh she has been talking to us about her
99 year old
her 99 year old mother now she's in
hospital at the moment
after an infection on her leg not
covered related
she was told repeatedly by staff that
it's not their policy to vaccinate
inpatients
yesterday jan got a call from the
hospital to tell her that her 99 year
old mother has picked up covered in
hospital
janet's mum 86 fell over broke her hip
in three places
she's in hospital staff their say they
said they're not vaccinating
inpatient so we have people potentially
in those top four
cohorts that we are trying to target who
are in a hospital environment which we
know is potentially quite dangerous
who are not being given the vaccine why
is that the case
uh neil so there is no policy to say
that hospitals shouldn't
uh vaccinate uh those who are eligible
in those four cohorts and both of your
examples are
eligible so there is no nhs policy on
that um
issue uh of course they are vaccinating
outpatients
um because that that is
what they wanted to do early on but it's
only right that they
make sure those in those cohorts are
also vaccinated i'll very happily look
at those cases
i'll say it again the 99 year old mother
of jan in hospital for an infection on
her leg repeatedly told that she
couldn't get the vaccine
contracts covered in a clinical
environment and then we have
one of your colleagues in in the
conservative party whose name escapes me
from the moment
did a day of vaccinating in a hospital
and picked up her doors
as i said to you there is no no policy
uh
from nhs england to um exclude people
uh who are eligible who are in hospital
from getting the vaccine
i will happily look at the the case that
you mentioned
everyone who's eligible will be offered
the vaccine by mid-february that is
our promise that is what we will deliver
that is my absolute commitment
to your viewers um of course if
someone's caught the infection
uh uh 28 days after that they will be
eligible for a vaccine
um as we have done with the residence of
care homes we will
vaccinate all residents of care homes uh
that are able to be vaccinated by
the ones that aren't currently uh with
covered
by the end of this month and the staff
in care homes as well so
our absolute commitment is those top
four categories the most
um vulnerable you know we're already at
uh i think
uh over 70 percent of
over 80s already uh with the first dose
of the vaccine and
we'll get protection from that within a
couple of weeks two three weeks
um and of course the other three cohorts
as well
but very happy to look at the case that
your reporter has brought up
and come back to you but there is no nhs
central policy
to prohibit hospitals from vaccinating
those who are eligible
who are in hospital